An end is pretty stupid. It doesn't
have much of a brain, no. Well,
no clan and yet many ants together.
A smart an ant colony can
construct complex structures.
Some colonies keep farms of Funky,
others take care of cattle.
They can wage war or defend themselves.
How is this possible?
How can a bunch of stupid
things do smart things together?
This phenomenon is called immersions
and it's one of the most fascinating and
mysterious features of our universe.
In a nutshell.
It describes small things forming bigger
things that have different properties
than the sum of their parts.
Emergence is complexity arising from
simplicity and immersions is everywhere.
Water has a vastly different properties
to the molecules that make it up like
the concept of wetness, teak, wet
fabric. If you zoom in far enough,
there is no wetness.
There are just molecules sitting in the
spaces between the atoms of the cloth.
Wetness is an emerging property of water,
something new only created by a lot of
individual interactions between water
molecules and this is sort of as many
things interact under a certain set of
rules, creating something
above and beyond themselves.
It turns out that more is different.
This different property is itself a new
thing and that new thing can couple with
other new things to repeat the process.
You can imagine this as layers
at stacked upon each other.
Every layer made from more
complex parts osms four molecules,
molecules form proteins.
Proteins make up cells,
cells make up organs,
organs form individuals,
individuals form societies,
but how can something be more
than the sum of its parts?
How do ams formed the sort
of cloudy entity that is a
colony by following a rule
set of the producers order through chaos.
For example,
let's look at how an ant
colony distributes jobs.
Let's assume that a colonies should
have 25% workers, 25% cat acres,
25% soldiers and 25% gatherers
and communicate their
current job via chemicals.
For example, a worker and constantly
secretes chemicals that say, I'm a worker.
When ants meet other ants, they smashed
each other to gather information,
telling each other their
job and what they are doing.
Both keep track of who
they met in the past.
Now imagine an anteater
kills most of the cataracts.
If this isn't fixed quickly,
the colony will staff.
Many work arounds need to switch jobs,
but how do you tell this to
thousands of them? Simple. You don't.
Our work around tool still meet
her, the smell, other ants,
but it will encounter
almost new gatherers at all.
It's counts too few gatherers until it
reaches a critical point and then it
changes its job.
The worker becomes a gatherer.
Other ants will do the
same until after a while.
There are enough gather as again,
the balance is restored all by itself.
The actions and interactions
of an individual are random.
You can't plan which,
and we'll encounter which other ENT,
but the simple set of rules is
so elegant that are colonies.
Many operations emerged as a consequence
on an even more fundamental level,
hundreds of millions of
complicated molecules interact
to maintain a robust and
amazing structure of being with vastly
different properties than the sum of its
dead parts emerges. The
smallest unit of life, the cell.
We still don't have a clear
definition of what living things are.
We just know the emerged from
things that are not alive.
Cells combine and cooperate.
They specialize and respond to one another
and over time we develop into complex
organisms with remarkable capacities.
Your arms and legs and heart are an
incredibly complex and complicated system
made of trillions of individual
stupid things and yet we read,
digest and watch youtube videos.
How do your cells know what to do? Think
of the pacemaker cells in your heart.
Billions of them need to send out an
impulse just at the right moment to
collectively create a heartbeat ourselves,
exchange chemical information with their
neighbors house to see what they're up
to and then decide what to do.
If it's among a lot of cells that
are working on the same task,
it will start working on that task
as well and sync up with them.
There is no master minds giving commands,
just single units communicating with their
neighbors and acting according to the
feedback they gas.
What about our most important part?
What is the thing that asks
these kinds of questions?
Is our consciousness then an immersion
property of the cells in our brain,
and this question is
too big and important.
It deserves a video of its own.
Some things that emerge are hard to
define. You can't touch an ant colony,
only its parts. It has
neither brain or face, nobody,
and yet the colony interacts with the
world just like colonies emerge from ans
things emerge from humans like nations.
What actually is the nation? Is it it's
population? Is it its institutions,
its symbols like it's
flag colors or anthems,
the physical things that makes links,
cities the territory it occupies.
All of these things are fluid.
Populations change and replaced.
Institutions come and go.
Cities can be constructed and abandoned.
Borders have changed all the time for
most of history and symbols get replaced
by new symbols. A nation
has no face, no brain,
no body on nations,
not real.
Then of course they are
just like ant colonies.
Nations interact with the world. They
can change landscapes, wage wars,
grow or decline,
and they can stop existing,
but they only exist because of a lot
of humans interacting with each other,
but not just nations. All
the complex structures that
surround us emerge from us,
even if we don't intend to.
We are constantly creating communities,
companies, cities, societies.
All of these things are entities that
have fundamentally different qualities and
abilities than the pretty
stupid apes they emerge. Trump,
we don't know why any of this happens.
We just observe it and it seems to be
a fundamental property of our universe.
It may be the most beautiful and
wondrous property of our universe.